Oh, you actually bought that car online yesterday.
Yeah.
You really that lazy?
Lazy?
Lazy as in the mother of invention?
Maybe I should go to the grocery store like a normal person..
...but I choose delivery for my kumquats.
And I choose to have a robot vacuum my floor.
Who else is gonna do that?
You?
Me?
I choose to ride the escalator going down...
...and to stream movies I own on DVD.
And to let social media remember birthdays for me.
I choose to wear the internet on my face.
It's open.
Hey, your car is here.
Nice.
So, I say to you what everyone knows.
Where there's a will, there's always a way to make it easier.
So you can judge me for choosing to date people by computational algorithm,...
...but you'll never get me to ask for a date in person...
...like some sort of animal or do anything else the old way.
Doug.
And yes, I choose to buy a Carvana car from my couch...
...and have it delivered to my front door with a seven-day test own.